you've shot in all kinds of places
you've been on the road you've been in
cars barns homes basements silos
everywhere you name it you've been there
you must have some great stories I could
tell a story yeah that's what that's
what people do when they come on a talk
show as they tell a story so yeah oh
they have a story that would be great
uh-oh
Goldilocks I can't do Goldilocks no no
no not I don't mean a story like that
yeah well I've never heard that one
you don't know he'll go he likes it yeah
that's a great one yeah great story I
don't know how much time we have left
but I'll speed through it essentially
Goldilocks is a kid little girl and she
is lost in the forest and so she's
running through the forest so she's
hungry she's seven seven and a half
maybe I don't know if it matters do you
think it's fine you know I think anyone
ever yeah cared it was just Goldilocks
so she's that little girl she's a girl
and she's in the wood does not in what
does she not have a parents it does not
impact the story is what Conan is where
did you get that cheese
things things are going pretty good for
me okay so anyway
Goldilocks she's exhausted and she's
hungry so she finally stumbles across
this house in the forest okay and she
knocks on the door and there's no answer
so she tries to doorknob in the door
open so she walks inside is so dangerous
yeah yeah but if she's fine
so she goes inside and she knows she's
so hungry she looks in the kitchen she
noticed there's a big bowl of porridge
and she tries that but it's too hot take
nobody ever brings these points up in
this boy yeah I don't know if it matters
but she does have I don't know do we
have time I says she tries the big
porridge too hot and then she tries to
another porch and porridge is hot than
somebody is home I know they were just
no they may have microwave didn't had to
take off yeah it's not a safe it's
unclear at first but anyway so she tries
another ball and it's too cold then she
tries then not the last Bowl she says
that's just right and so she eats it all
up then she's tired so she goes in the
living room and she sits on her chair
and she says this chair is too big and
then she sits on another chair is too
big
it's a bigger chair than she wanted so I
know she hops on the next chair and then
she's weird you know I hope guys enough
a chair yeah it's too big or got extra
room you don't complain yeah I think she
has a point
who said this chair is too big you can't
see at home but they all stood I don't
have a lot of time they're saying okay
to get through this yeah the audience
yeah that's you so she sits in first
year too big next year please take then
the next chair she sits in is also too
big she finally sits the one says that's
just right but then the chair breaks so
Goldilocks now gets up and she's
exhausted so she goes upstairs she gets
upstairs and she lies in a bed she says
this bed is too hard and then she lies
in a second bed she says this bed is too
soft and then she sits in the last
benches as this bed is just right and
she falls asleep huh yeah at this point
the Bears the Bears come home and oh my
god what there's bears yeah the Bears
come on there's bears so the Bears come
home there's three of them there's momma
poppa in the little girl okay so the
Bears there are bears yes I don't have
time the Bears come home the Bears go up
go into the kitchen they knows someone's
been eating my porridge hey pop yeah
they got and then they go into the
living room they notice someone was
sitting in my chair the other one says
someone was sitting in my chair and then
I would never know it's always sitting
in my chair story then they go upstairs
they noticed that someone's been lying
in my bed and then the other says
someone's been lying in my bed and the
last one says someone's going to my bed
and they're still here and then
Goldilocks suddenly wakes up and says
help and she gets up she runs out of the
house and then yeah she broke into the
house she runs outside she gets to the
sitting team out here then she vows she
vows that she'll never return to the
forest again okay well you have a story
cuz that's about out of time is it about
really like a good yeah it's about the
three little pissed off for God's no
we're not gonna give no we're not doing
you three little pigs
you